Mr. Feigjón,
you said in the campaign that,
of being President,
would all laws
approved by Euskal Herria Bildu.
Well,
if after this week it continues here
representing his party,
It's going to have to see a lot more laws,
many more achievements and many more advances
that will bear the seal
by Euskal Herria Bildu as well.
Look,
sir fixed,
it turns out that
Thanks to the decisions of Euskal Herria Bildu,
all Basques,
all Basque women saw their salaries
and increased pensions,
rents can be controlled
and promote access to housing.
Thanks also to Euskal Herria bildus,
will apply taxes to banks,
electricity companies and large fortunes.
We gave our word
that we would keep the window of opportunity open
to achieve these new advances
that citizens demand and demand.
Therefore,
we will not give the right wing any chance.
By oraindic disgust,
dushue and kusteco,
squid,
hand andereak,
Buruja,
Becha gyago,
Naidugo Scooby,
Social Doo,
gyago babés,
labor,
gyago feminism,
gayago,
ETA ascata is 1 gayago asquenciñean,
Shrek Gorroto,
Dussuen service,
Naidu Gulakobu,
democracy,
Gaya Goku,
gorretarakomodu,
erai kidshayean were,
summear,
kosayela,
Gurerrien,
Aldari,
cap social,
ETA was born in the law,
it is Astu,
Euskal Herrico,
Yes, poet,
Galicia,
koesker,
esker, zubira,
Gabe nistari,
skun muturra gaur,
rules Chen egongouli chatequé